if you're going into Barbarian for the
first time you might think that the bad
guy is going to be key the suspicious
fellow played by Bill Skarsgard after
the secret beneath the barbaric Airbnb
is revealed Keith Falls victim to the
film's True Villain the mother a large
naked aggressive woman who lives in the
tunnel system below the house Matthew
Patrick Davis portrays the mother in all
her glory Davis's on-screen work has
been predominantly on TV shows and short
films making Barbarian an interesting
change of pace in a chat with no Film
School Davis revealed that he booked the
Barbarian gig by sending in a self tape
of himself half naked baby birding a
pickle into an imaginary victim's mouth
Davis's efforts paid off though as his
performance helped make Barbarian one of
the biggest surprises of 2022. to see
the full video and more great content
check out our Channel And subscribe